Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu raum zeit dem podcast über raumfahrt und andere kos minus logische angelegenheiten
mein name ist tim und ich begrüße alle hier zur mittlerweile sogar achtzigsten ausgabe von raum seid,
so oft um technik um wissenschaft geht wo wir uns heute mal so ein bisschen mehr mit der strategischen ausrichtung der raumfahrt speziell der raumfahrt europas unterhalten und ja.
Hatte ich auch mal ganz zu beginn hier dieser serie mit dem damaligen vorstandsvorsitzenden des wdr
jan burner getan das ist jetzt schon eine weile her wie ich festgestellt habe acht jahre zeit für ein update und ich freue mich besonders heute mit einem
anderen vorstandsmitglied der ddr sprechen zu dürfen nämlich mit hansjörg titus schönen guten tag herzlich willkommen zu raum zeit,
sie sind physiker richtig.
Das stimmt ja georg physiker und physiker.
Georg physiker von daher eigentlich wunderbar untergebracht hier beim wdr würde ich sagen.
Na ja gut es war schon wechseln weil man ja sehr viele ich bin jetzt schon lange in der raum vorzeit neunzehnhundertsiebenundachtzig und nicht alles beim dialog auch in der universität,
aber die verbindung von ingenieurswissenschaften physik ist das was man in der raumfahrt eigentlich braucht.
Und wollen sie denn von vornherein die raumfahrt gehen oder war das etwas was ich erst später ergeben hat.
Das war jetzt zufall also ich hab mich jetzt nicht unbedingt geplant gehabt aber manchmal das war ein ende der achtziger jahre war das eine gute gelegenheit.
Und ich hab mich dann entschlossen eigentlich dachte ich das mache ich mal eine weile guck mir das alles an,
dann gehe ich wieder zurück mittlerweile bin ich aber hängen geblieben sind zweiundzwanzig jahre den raum verbind ich meine dreißig jahre so zweiunddreißig jahre jetzt schon,
vergisst es dann immer und was aber gut ist wie ich habe heute wieder vieles was,
mich im laufe der jahre eingeholt hat in der physik in der physik auch wenn sie sich vorstellen wenn wir heute auf,
planetarium mission planen das alles geht wie es wie es mal kennengelernt hab früher und.
Ganz spannend auch die erdbeeren beachtung ist meistens musik in reinkultur.
Jetzt sind wir in köln aber sie haben viel ihrer zeit in bremen verbracht einer universität bremen ich das richtig sehe auch schon früh mit ja,
den fundamentalen kräften zu tun gehabt unter anderem glaube ich waren sie auch mit dem fall turm beschäftigt.
Das war mein erstes projekt das hab ich bereits neunzehnhundertsiebenundachtzig begonnen und damals das war ja noch vor der wende zeit,
gab es eben viele aufbruchstimmung und zusätzlich eine aufbruchstimmung im damals,
etwas gebäuden bremen das durch seine werfen begleiten,
versucht hat dann auch anderes in anderer stelle fuß zu fassen und die universität die damals in großem aufbruch war,
hat mich überzeugt dann hab ich dann damals dahin gegangen und wir haben als eines der großen projekte den fall tom realisiert und ich hatte das glück dass ich dort gleich projektleiter wurde es war natürlich ein tolles projekt bei dem man.
Genau die erfahrung sammeln kann auch die man für spätere aufgaben braucht es war groß aber nicht so groß wie heute manches raumfahrt projekt läuft ja.
Ja trotzdem ist ja dieses ganze forschung in schwerelosigkeit ein wichtiges thema an der stelle kann auch gleich nochmal an eine meiner längsten sendung hier bei raum seid verweisen wo ich mit ihrer kollegin ulrike friedrich ausführlich
über all die ganzen aspekte gesprochen hatte kurz nachdem ich auch selber die möglichkeit hatte,
mit einer mit der kampagne mal mit zu fliegen und das ganze mitzubekommen die faszination kann ich auf jeden fall sehr gut nachvollziehen,
ja aber letztlich hatte sie über umwege zum ddr gebracht,
dort sind sie jetzt seit zweitausendelf im vorstand wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Umwege waren's nicht also es ist natürlich ein ziemlich zielstrebig gewinnen weil klar war dass wir in bremen wo ja sehr viele industrielle aktivität ist eben auch groß forschung brauchen es waren ja auch überlegungen die,
strategisch über viele jahre gelaufen sind und wir haben uns dann.
Im jahr zweitausendfünf zweitausendsechs entschlossen den vorstoß zu machen und dort in groß forschungseinrichtungen vorzuschlagen,
dass er dann auch realisiert worden ist relativ schnell zweitausendsechs und ich bin dann zweitausendacht dort direkt an dem neuen institut geworden dass wir aus meinem alten institut nämlich dem zentrum für angewandte raumfahrt technologien mikro kavitation,
konzeptionell entwickelt hatten.
Jetzt ist sie zuständig für raumfahrt forschung und technologie das ja ein weites feld.
Technologie für raumfahrt muss man socken krasse raus steht raumfahrt technologie davor also nicht nur also insofern ist raumfahrt in tote ja das stimmt also es ist wirklich alles.
Jetzt war das auch schon für mich ein wechsel in den vorstand als instituts der,
aber ich muss dazu sagen ich habe natürlich mit vielen aspekten der raumfahrt vorher auch schon zu tun gehabt.
Nicht nur mit dem thema mikro mikro gravitation also forschung der schwerelosigkeit wir haben uns dann sehr schnell auch mit satelliten beschäftigt um,
experimente zu machen zum thema fundamentale physik dann hat man dann so themen wie lager regelung genereller satelliten bau wir müssen den überhaupt gestaltet sein damit man messungen machen kann mit denen man zum beispiel,
gravitationswellen noch sehen kann auf satelliten wie genau muss man die steuern und so bin ich eigentlich fast durch alle bereiche der raumfahrt durchgelaufen,
bevor ich dann ähm das institut für raumfahrt systeme in bremen übernommen hab das einzige was für mich noch offene thema aber mit dem hab ich mich mittlerweile intensiv beschäftigt,
war das thema raumfahrt antriebe also das was eigentlich die satelliten ins weltall befördert.
Und das ist doch eines der großen wichtigen bereiche die wir heute einen raum von forschung an der technologieentwicklung haben nämlich wie kriegen wir unsere satelliten möglichst,
schnell und günstig ins weltall.
Ja da sind ja auch immer noch sehr eng mit beschäftigt das werden wir sicherlich gleich nochmal ansprechen,
ja zeiten wandel.
Ganz interessant oder eigentlich schade vor zwei tagen ist sigmund gestorben,
sicherlich ein klares zeichen für,
diesen wandel weil er repräsentiert halt diese diese alte raumfahrt ja natürlich damals noch in der ddr war er war ja auch nach nach dem ende der ddr eine wichtige person,
in der raumfahrt immer präsent bei allen staats wo es sich leisten konnte,
zugegen wir hatten immer ein sehr intensives verhältnis will er,
und sieg montieren oder.
Ja also das ich stehe auch heute noch unter dem eindruck des todes von dem ich gestern morgen erfahren habe,
das ist schon eine traurige geschichte ich habe ihn auch persönlich gut kennengelernt und.
Er war immer ein sehr optimistischer mensch in richtung raumfahrt und auch sonst eine sehr angenehme,
scheitern sehr zielstrebig agieren.
Ich bin sehr traurig dass wir ihn nicht mehr haben also das war ein enges verhältnis und mit uns mit dem gesamten aber ich habe ihn wie gesagt durch viele gespräche auch kennengelernt hab viel erzählt viele lustige dinge,
viele wichtige dinge und ich glaube ihr habt viel von ihm gelernt.
Ich hatte auch die gelegenheit hier eine folge von raum zeit mit ihm gemeinsam zu machen ist schon eine weile her zweitausendelf war das,
aber mir ist es auch aufgefallen dass viele von dem worüber wir gesprochen haben im prinzip,
sehr gut in diese sendung auch hinein mündet weil er sich ja auch sehr viel gedanken darüber gemacht hat wohin es sich eigentlich alles entwickeln sollte.
Ja das hat er also ich war ja so ein wandler zwischen den politischen welten auch und hat das glaub ich gut transportiert.
Was ich immer schön finde oder was ich mir heute was mir gestern noch überlegt.
Man spricht ja immer so von den helden der raumfahrt da gibt's ja viel ich glaube der war einer,
der war einer weil er eben auch seine rolle sehr glaubhaft gemacht nicht gespielt hat aber sie rüber gebracht hat also sein seine sein wesen war so er konnte,
die menschen auch zusammenbringen durch seine ruhige und vor allem unglaublich bescheid eine art.
Ja dann kommen wir doch mal zu dem worüber ich heute eigentlich sprechen wollt und das ganze ist ein bisschen ausgelöst einfach durch diese vielen änderungen die sich eigentlich in der raumfahrt in den letzten jahren ergeben haben,
das thema ist nachdem es auch so lange so ein bisschen gefühlt und dornröschenschlaf gelebt hat jetzt so ein bisschen wieder neu entfacht vor allem durch die aktivitäten,
in den usa durch die privatisierung der raumfahrt technologie durch unternehmen
wie space x und vor allem was uns ja auch bevorsteht und damit würde ich vielleicht gerne mal einsteigen
ist das ja auch die internationalen raumstation ja im prinzip so das symbol der raumfahrt war nachdem die phase der mond fahrten beendet war,
dass sie es ist ja nun eigentlich nur noch wenige jahre vor sich hat auf dem papier wie sehen sie denn.
Die situation der is derzeit und wie lange rechnen sie noch damit dass diese station genutzt werden kann.
Ich hoffe dass sie nun lange genutzt werden kann aber ich bedaure ein wenig dass wir nicht drüber nachdenken,
durch was für sie ersetzen oder nicht intensiv genug darüber nachdenken wir tun es jedenfalls im dialog gerne und viel.
Weil wir der meinung sind egal was wir machen im weltraum ob wir jetzt zum mond oder zum maß eines tages fliegen egal was wir machen bedarf es davor vorbereitung,
insbesondere wenn wir menschen ins weltall bringen auf einer internationalen station im erdnahen orbit und was ich auch bedauere ist dass wir,
eine solche station nicht mehr nutzen auch im hinblick auf das was die großen aufgaben der raum verträglich sind ist ja nicht dass wir zum mond oder zum maß fliegen das ist ja nicht die große aufgabe darauf war die große aufgabe der raumfahrt.
Sind die beobachtung unserer erde,
hinsichtlich einer gigantischen aufgabe nämlich zur beobachtung des globalen wandels global change von dem der klimawandel nur ein kleiner teil ist.
Und wir hätten mit dieser station ein instrument wenn man sie den ordentlich nutzen würde.
Eben auch unabhängige neutrale beobachtung machen zu können das heißt nicht durch national aufgestelltes,
oder in gesellschaft system wie der wie europa aufgestellten satelliten mission die natürlich immer so auch die intention haben oder wahrscheinlich haben werden,
die eigene position zurecht zu rücken im blick auf eine globale überwachung sondern eben auch allen nationen die wie überall sind und die nicht raumfahrt machen können die chance geben,
ergebnisse zu bekommen zum klimawandel wenn man sie ihn auf einer großen internationalen raumstation machen würde also ich würde mich freuen wenn wir diese internationale raumstation nicht nur,
also einer raumstation hätte in der zukunft die von fünf gesellschaft system betrieben werden weltweit sondern sie als eine wirklich auch internationale station sehen würden,
sensorik hätten die für jedermann zugänglich ist die unabhängig.
Unbestechlich das zeigt was wir jeden tag beobachten nämlich an extrem massiven menschen gemachten wandel unserer gesamten erde.
Und damit logischerweise auch das klima es ist ja nur ein kleiner teil davon.
Die landnutzung.
Landnutzung aber natürlich auch im hinblick auf die ernährungssicherheit von.
Sieben milliarden menschen wahrscheinlich in diesem jahrhundert noch auf zehn milliarden steigend,
das sind schon die galt die gigantische aufgaben und raumfahrt kann zur beobachtung glaube ich wesentlich beitragen aber vor allem auch dann datenbasis liefern die die möglichkeit,
zur lösung schaffen modelle verbessern insbesondere zum beispiel klima modelle aber auch andere modelle die wir haben und da braucht man raumfahrt massiv und intensiv.
Und da kann eine internationale raumstation nur nützen.
Mein tipp ist immer wir müssen sie umbenennen von station in observatorium es ist eine beobachtung station dafür könnte man sie nutzen viel intensiver als man es in der vergangenheit getan hat.
Wer sieht denn diese chancen und wer sind denn diese chancen nicht also die pläne sind derzeit wenn ich es richtig sehe dass so.
Nach den aktuellen verträgen das ganze ende der zwanziger jahre,
zum abschluss kommen soll ist das überhaupt realistisch.
Naja.
Zum abschluss zum ende kommt.
Weil eine station wie die die wir jetzt haben kommt natürlich in die jahre.
Wie jedes haus irgendwann werden sie es renovieren müssen mit viel aufwand und irgendwann macht es vielleicht auch mal sehen was neues zu machen was die frage ist wenn man.
Man braucht es für immer werde natürlich die frage wann fangen wir mit dem renovieren an.
Wenn man es für immer braucht und davon bin ich fest überzeugt,
dann kann man es nicht ersetzen mit irgendwas anderem wo man dann zum mond oder zum maß fliegt sondern da braucht es zusätzlich und dann wäre es natürlich sinnvoll wenn man früh dran geht und sagt wie können wir denn die kosten reduzieren.
Wenn sie mal die weltweiten kosten die wir heute im jahr brauchen um diese raumstation am leben zu halten zusammen zählen wird das geld dann kommen wir,
wobei wir jetzt nicht alle zahlen genau kennen weil wir bestimmte zahlen zum beispiel russische raumfahrt haushalt wird nicht ganz so genau kennen,
aber ich will mal schätzen wir sind bei einer summe in der größenordnung von viereinhalb milliarden euro im jahr die wir brauchen um diese station am leben zu halten das ist natürlich schon die frage kann man das billiger und günstiger machen.
Was es teuer macht sind die vielen transport mission die man dahin macht zur versorgung auf zum transport von menschen wir sind nämlich heute in der lage jetzt.
Nachdem wir,
dreißig jahre weiter sind nachdem wir angefangen haben die station zu planen die haben wir schon nach zigarren anfang planen dass man sie auch günstiger planen könnte aber wir planen andere dinge nicht die die uns nahelegen weil es vielleicht nicht so.
Nicht so interessant gilt dann könnte man natürlich viel geld sparen also unsere schätzungen die wir aus unseren modellen haben ist dass man.
Durch eine clevere vielleicht auch kleiner aufgesetzte raumstation die mehr modulare ist das heißt also kette von modulen bildet im orbit,
betriebskosten im jahr sparen könnte für zwei komma fünf milliarden bestimmt zwei bis zweieinhalb milliarden das heißt man könnte weltweit,
zwei milliarden im jahr gewinnen die man dann zur programme wie mond und mars einsetzen könnte das geld haben wir momentan nicht aber es ist natürlich auch eine.
Meiner ansicht nach schwierige überlegung zu sagen die würden diese raumstation eines tages,
ich glaube das macht auch momentan keiner mehr diese überlegung das war mal so,
und machen dann nur noch mond oder nur noch maß oder solche dinge.
Denn die vorbereitung für menschen in flüge richtung montag der mars.
Natürlich nur in einer sicheren umgebung wie wir sie in der raumstation haben,
dort sind wir sicher vor all zu holen strahlendes ist weil dort sind wir sicher äh was die möglichkeiten der versorgung von menschen angeht im fall dass sie zum beispiel krank werden oder dinge passieren das haben sie alles auf maß und mond flügen nicht.
Und insofern wird man sie brauchen wenn man solche gigantischen programme angeht anfängt.
Meine viereinhalb milliarden klickt für sich natürlich jetzt erstmal noch eine menge geld aber es ist ja nicht so dass diese ist es auch keine ergebnisse liefern würde man es ist ja ein.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt also die liefert natürlich ergebnisse.
Der aber die sichtweise der öffentlichkeit macht sich natürlich schnell an solchen dingen fest so nach dem motto ja da vier milliarden das könnte man ja auch für fügen sie hier ihr lieblingsthema ein ausgeben,
aber.
Ich denke was selten genug transportiert wird ist dass es sich um einen permanenten forschungs- ort handelt der letzten endes auch konkrete ergebnisse.
Und ein beobachtung dort eben auch wir beobachten die aus von oben wie können sie war nicht die ganze erde beobachten weil sie auf einer sehr niedrigen inflation pflegte kommt ja nur etwa fünfzig grad nord und süd an.
Aber unter fünfzig grad söder nord liegen alle fast alle.
Großen städte dieser erde ich würde mal sagen,
menschen leben in diesem band nördlich und südlich der situation.
So dass wir damit tatsächlich auch den einfluss des menschen gut quartieren könnten unabhängig von natürlich von den satelliten die wir haben die ersetzen die satelliten diese hochpräzise,
beobachtung satelliten nicht aber sie können eine sie kann eine vergleichbarkeit schaffen zu den messungen und vor allem.
Sie könnte eben auch den zugang für andere öffnen wenn man sie wirklich international machen würde das ist.
Was heißt denn könnte also wird diese beobachtung fähigkeit des is derzeit noch nicht voll genutzt.
Nein wird nicht voll genutzt wir haben ja nur sehr begrenzte möglichkeiten etwa der beobachtung auf außen plattform.
Das geht nicht so das wie man das hätte es gibt einige instrumente da oben.
Der vorteil in einer raumstation ist natürlich sie kriegen ihre instrumente sehr schnell nach oben.
Sie haben eine dauerzustand sie können die instrumente sogar eichen reparieren sie können sie über lange zeit nebeneinander her betreiben dass er zum beispiel das wesen große observatorium musik da komme ich ja nur her.
Dass man eben viele generationen von instrumenten betreibt um auch die kalibrieren fehler zu sehen das können wir auf satelliten alles gar nicht,
also sie würde eine reihe von vorteilen bieten gegenüber einem satelliten programm wo sich permanent die dinge ablösen satellit,
lässt sich nicht reparieren der ist irgendwann ausgedient und wird ersetzt durch was anderes und dann ist er meistens anders.
Und die anschluss messung sind auch ein gewisses problem aber was natürlich noch viel entscheidender ist.
Sie können die instrumente die sie oben haben.
Durch wartung und beobachtung über einen langen zeitraum so einsetzen.
Dass die beobachtung reinkriegen die ungebrochen sind das schaffen sie auf satelliten in der regel nicht was hat viele vorteile aber immer nur eine ergänzung zu dem was wir auf beobachtung satelliten auch machen,
ich bin großer fan dieser raumstation auch mit menschen denn die menschen brauchen wir damit wir diese instrumente dort,
und jetzt zu sagen das programm läuft irgendwann aus und manche sagen hoffentlich bald dann immer ganz viel geld frei für andere sachen ist ein fehler definitiv wir müssen solche raumstationen internet oder eine zumindestens international halten.
Du hast unsere meinung ist dass wir sie nicht mehr so betreiben dürfen wie wir 's momentan betreiben nämlich als großer block.
Sondern eher in modulen die wie so 'ne kette aufgereiht entlang eines orbans fliegen sodass man auch mal ein modul rausnehmen kann einen neuen reinbringen kann dass man private und öffentliche aktivitäten koppeln kann.
Das ist ja auch ein problem dass wir auf der raumstation haben dass das nicht gar nicht so einfach ist wie sie immer klingt und dass man sowas wie,
conor die ja immer so groß gelobt wird auch mal leben kann,
denn äh ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass news basic kondome so ohne weiteres bei zielen wie mond und maß wirkt ja sondern das wird man nur ein erdnahen orbit machen dort kann man unter umständen produzieren,
dort kann man beobachten kann dinge beobachten die für den allgemeinen interesse sind die wirtschaftlich verwertbar sind.
Und dort kann man dinge ausprobieren eben auch für die industriellen einsätze die produktion oder so.
Verstehe ich das richtig so 'ne kette reden wir von einem umbau oder an einem neubau um ein solches konzept verfolgen zu können.
Ja beides beides wir haben natürlich viele elemente die kann man verwenden in so eine konzeption gibt's auch bei uns studien aber wird auch den ein oder anderen modul neu bauen müssen,
und das ist ja auch so ein bisschen problem das wir haben wir müssen eine industrie auch beschäftigen das ist ja nicht so momentan machen wir viel planung auf papier,
wie es weitergeht und vieles wird in studien umgesetzt aber es war ich brauchen ist hardware und zwar wird jetzt hardware gebaut in richtung mond.
Aber man könnte natürlich durchaus auch zum beispiel plattform bauen wo wir diese erde beobachtung in zukunft viel.
Also ein netzwerk an an modulen die wir um die erde kreisen lassen.
So dass man sie wie so eine kleine stadt mit unterschiedlichen häusern.
Die alle ihren zweck haben aufbaut aber die gemeinsamkeiten nutzt nämlich zum beispiel den raum transport.
Oder die logistik gemeinsam durchführt dann können sie alles nebeneinander her führen was wir momentan so gar nicht können das sehr sehr schwierig wie ich schon sagte etwa private einzubinden,
in diese staatlich finanzierter einrichtungen das sind viele gesetzliche regelungen zu beachten,
auch sicherheitsrelevanten das würden private vielleicht manchmal ganz anders machen das sehen wir immer wieder dass es nicht ganz so einfach ist und da kann man ja mal überlegen ob man nicht,
eine ja so ein netzwerk an modulen im orbit schafft die.
Zeitweise zusammenhängen können aber auch wieder entfernt werden können wir haben das konzept sehr weitgehend bereits ausgearbeitet und diskutieren das mit vielen unserer partner.
Also das würde bedeuten dass man quasi diesen ort der raumstation nicht nur nutzt um an die raumstation selbst etwas anzubauen und zu erweitern sollen gegebenenfalls auch in unmittelbarer nähe separat davon fliegende
teile noch im betrieb nimmt dir aber dann auch davon profitieren dass man eben mit diesem versorgungs- flügen die ohnehin stattfinden auch diese module mit versorgen könnte.
Ja wie so eine kleine stadt die waren dann hätte kleine gut ist natürlich sind wie viele module dieser art,
aber man ist sehr viel flexibler wenn man modulare rangeht weil man dann auch,
schneller reagieren kann wenn etwas veraltet oder neue ideen ausprobiert werden müssen,
momentan ist es ein schwieriger akt auf diese raumstation zu kommen ist nicht einfach sich vorstellen wir haben,
vorläufe bei manchen experimenten die bis zu zehn jahre dauern dass es nicht sehr flexibel.
Und viel instrumenten bau läuft so dass es schwierig anzupassen sind viele sicherheitsrelevanten zu beachten im unmittelbaren umfeld der raumstation müssen ja unfälle vermieden werden die werden ja das leben der astronauten da oben gefährdet,
und manchmal ist es einfacher man hätte module die eher unbenannt sind die man nur ab und zu.
Das würde uns deutlich größere flexibilität auf dauer geben.
Alles müsste geplant werden unter dem gesichtspunkt dass die gesamtkosten im betrieb sich wesentlich reduzieren das glaube ich kann man erreichen und dann hätte man auch viel mehr geld frei für das was man dann.
In ferner zukunft oder in 'ner ganz nahe zukunft wie viele hoffen auf montag maß machen.
Also wenn ich sie richtig verstehe plädieren sie für so eine lang
eine erneute langfristige planung dieses standorts das war jetzt nicht nur im klein klein mit hängen wir nochmal drei jahre dran und treiben das im wesentlichen so wie es jetzt ist
nicht nur nicht nur in diesem bereich denkt und plant saß man sagt okay jetzt jetzt haben wir diese basis noch jetzt ist es in gewisser hinsicht auch noch
einfach
bestimmte dinge dort zu entwickeln wäre die überhaupt gar nicht mehr da muss man ja im prinzip wieder,
komplett von vorne anfangen und zwar nicht nur weil er nichts fliegt sondern,
weil ja auch nichts entstehen kann
ohne dass man eine industrie hat die auch in der lage ist diese ganze technologie voranzutreiben und zu zu bauen die probleme versteht und am laufenden mit damit beschäftigt man muss ja auch irgendjemand da sein
der das baut und betreibt und versteht und sich über lösung von problemen gedanken macht.
Genau das ist der punkt und man braucht.
Wenn man zu fernziel aufbricht auch 'ne strategie wie man das aus dem erdnahen orbit unterstützt wie gesagt wir können dort all die experimente erstmal machen zum beispiel die vorbereitung für astronauten für langzeit flüge.
Muss man immer betonen wir haben wenn wir uns außerhalb des strahlend der erde befinden also der in hohen höhen des beginnt bei zehntausend kilometer schon,
bewegen wir uns in einem umfeld bei dem wir strahlenbelastung zwischen dem einhundert und bis zu eintausend fachen auf dem mond haben von dem was wir auf der erde haben ein montag.
Montag nicht ein montag ein montag entsprechend tausend tagen was die strahlenbelastung angeht also die hochenergetische strahlenbelastung strahlung.
Sprich drei jahre das heißt nach neunzig tagen auf dem mond haben sie ihre lebenslust erreicht als astronaut wenn sie sie nie anderweitig schützen können.
Nicht nur nicht nur die astronauten auch die geräte.
Wir sind bis heute in der lage astronauten.
Etwa ein halbes jahr im orbit zu halten das sind diese regel flüge zu.
So dass sie sehr gesund wiederkommen schon bei einem jahr das wird ja auch ausprobiert gibt es doch erhebliche gesundheitsprobleme noch das muss man alles erstmal erforschen.
Und ich glaube die größten probleme die wir derzeit haben wenn wir langzeit pflege machen etwa in richtung maß ist tatsächlich die gesundheit der menschen wenn die menschen dabei sein sollen.
Man muss aber auch die kosten faktoren sehen wissen sie wenn sie heute zum mond fliegen,
dann brauchen sie etwa fünfmal mehr geld als das was wir brauchen heute um eine solche raumstation zu betreiben das programm das man dahinter hat ist gewaltig sind nicht nur dass man da ab und zu mal hinfliegt sie müssen,
erkundung mission machen sie müssen unbemannte versorgungs- missionen machen um eine station auf dem mond zu halten.
Braucht man viel mehr geld als mans heute für die erde offiziell als es reicht sowieso nicht selbst wenn man jetzt die raumstation zu machen würde und alles dieses geld in den mund programm stolz stopfen würde.
Wäre es wahrscheinlich immer noch nicht genug und das muss man eben auch sehen also mond.
Aber auch maß bedeutet viel mehr geld also nach unserer einschätzung wird man für eine.
Mond station die regelmäßig angeflogen gewartet und betrieben wird.
Etwa fünfmal mehr geld brauchen dass wir heute haben für das thema bemannten raumfahrt und etwa zwanzig mal mehr wenn wir auf dem mars fliegen.
Das ist nicht da das geld müssen wir sehen.
Wir sind in dem zusammenhang die position der,
nasa die vielleicht nicht unbedingt die position der nasa selbst ist aber quasi ihr auftrag ab zwanzig fünfundzwanzig ihren teil auf der is,
privat weiter zu reichen ich weiß nicht genau wie die pläne jetzt genau feststellen und formuliert sind ob das überhaupt alles schon in trockenen tüchern ist aber es,
ändert sich ja derzeit etwas in der art und weise wie die usa in ihren teil herangeht.
Ja man muss immer unterscheiden was heißt privat nutzen wir sind was die private nutzung angeht heute auf der raumstation im bereich unter einem prozent.
Kann keiner erwarten dass man das hundert prozent hinkriegt eines tages die frage ist ob man eine art kommerziellen betrieb hat also betriebsausgaben.
Wie zum beispiel transport arbeiten privatunternehmen zu.
Also vergleichbar wäre etwa,
im öffentlichen leben unserer zeit die müllabfuhr oder was das sind die dinge die könnten sie privatisieren das heißt aber nicht dass die öffentliche hand dann aus der zahlungspflichtig rauskommt sondern man muss dinge vielleicht kann man,
das ist die frage besser kommerziell in ausschreibungen organisieren bahn macht es ja heute auch es gibt der flugverkehr geht über private airlines,
aber sie müssen natürlich viele dinge staatlich trotzdem behalten bereit halten also sie brauchen ein flight controller ja das ist natürlich eine staatliche aufgabe.
Das heißt vieles der kosten werden natürlich immer noch über die öffentliche hand übernommen das kriegt man nicht weg die hoffnung ist dass man über gewisse privatisierung.
Und kommerzielle werbung kosten einsparen kann aber die nutzung der station selber.
Durch private das ist sehr gering und wird auch gering bleiben.
Das heißt was wir interpretieren sie jetzt die diskussion die da in dem zusammenhang in usa stattfindet.
Na ja gut das wars diskutiert wird es wird immer verwechselt also die wissen auch dass ich da nicht jetzt eine raumstation einfach vergeben können dass er macht eure forschung drauf und hier wird schon,
das was gemeint ist der kommerzielle betrieb die kommerzielle werbung des betriebs also die machen heute ausschreibungen im thema transport zum beispiel seit der der der beste,
transport leistung macht kriegt den zuschlag,
die machen heute ausschreibungen im betrieb für den betrieb der raumstation der den kostengünstigsten preis gekriegt den zuschlag alles was früher rein staatlich war wird heute auf diese weise auch soll auf diese weise organisiert werden,
die hoffnung nun muss man natürlich das amerikanische thema oder die amerikanische politik was raumfahrt angeht auch ein bisschen anders betrachten als wir es in europa tun.
Die tat dort sind enorm hoch wir haben äh bei nase allein etat der liegt bei zweiundzwanzig komma fünf milliarden us-dollar also das gewaltig,
es gibt einen für uns nicht.
Bekannten sehr hohen etat allein im department auf die fans das heißt raumfahrt ist er dort nicht nur ein thema für forschung und leben im all und den mond oder den master kunden.
Sondern es ist ein großes thema der strategischen aufstellung und.
Das ist ja hier in europa gar nicht der fall oder wächst erst zu langsam,
wenn sie die ganzen etat sehen dann können sie sagen im günstigsten fall,
haben die usa wahrscheinlich ein raumfahrt haushalt der fünfmal größeres als der rest der welt und im ungünstigsten zehnmal größer das heißt die gehen da ganz anders ran als wir herangehen können ja wir können kleine beiträge liefern in ein großes programm.
Und das amerikanische programm auf das nasal programm ist natürlich stark von den strategischen entscheidungen abhängig das muss man immer so sehen strategie die wir in europa jetzt gerade erstmal beginnen wenn sie,
jetzt verfolgt haben die aufstellung der neuen kommission in europa,
die kommissionspräsidenten hat ja nun ein offener leyen hat den plan bekannt gegeben und es gibt jetzt zum ersten mal,
eine general direktion die fans and space für europa das zeigt sich dass europa sich anders aufstellt zu dem thema als in der vergangenheit.
Im im rahmen der eu kommission.
Im rande eu-kommission das ist also jetzt auch eine andere aufstellung dass man überhaupt erst mal so eine general direktion jetzt geschaffen hat ist ja schon mal ein zeichen in welche richtung das auch.
Und diese strategische aufstellung bestimmt natürlich im wesentlichen dann in zukunft es weitergeht aber was u s a r angeht ist sehr speziell.
Für uns ist nicht immer ganz klar rauszubekommen warum welcher vorschlag gemacht wird,
wir lernen das dann immer so mit phasen verzug von ein bis zwei jahren.
Jetzt auch wieder so sein also wir deuten gerade noch wo es gerade hingeht.
Was würden sie denn von dem herangehensweise der amerikaner auch in europa gerne sehen und was denken sie ist hier überhaupt nicht vermittelbar und passt auch nicht zum europäischen ansatz.
Ich finde wir sollten uns weniger darum kümmern was die amerikaner vorschlagen dass wir da mitmachen irgendwie ist schon klar aber das werden wir eh nicht beeinflussen können also das wird dort entschieden,
es wird dort mit den möglichkeiten die sie haben entschieden mit den strategischen überlegungen,
auch in der präsident administration wir sollten doll in in deutschland aber speziell natürlich und das ist wissen wir eingebettet in europa europäisches programm ein eigenes europäisches programm entwickeln,
dass wir dann versuchen einzufangen aber zunächst mal uns selber drüber im clown zu sein was wir wollen ist glaube ich wichtig.
Deutschland ist ein großer beitragszahler in die eure,
raumfahrt programme sowohl auf eu als auch auf isa ebene.
Und da wäre es natürlich wichtig oder ist sehr wichtig dass wir wissen was wir ungefähr wollen das können wir dann mit unseren partnern weltweit.
Aber es ist immer schwierig wenn man sagt man macht mit und ist dann komplett abhängig von dem was woanders ganz woanders entschieden wird.
Und insofern plädiere immer dafür dass wir ein starkes europäisches programm aufstellen bei dem wir.
Auf viel auf eigenständigkeit setzen ja es geht nicht immer so wir können nicht allein zum maß fliegen wir können auch nicht allein zum mond fliegen aber wir können viele dinge allein machen das machen wir ja auch,
und und dann andere dazu einladen mitzumachen also europa müsste meiner ansicht nach sehr viel stärker,
eigenständig ein auto autonom vorgehen im gerade im bereich space aber vielleicht kommt das ja eine.
Haben sie glaube ich auch meine frage ein bisschen falsch verstanden ich meinte gar nicht so sehr mit wo sollten wir mitmachen was die amerikaner machen sondern,
die auch die kulturelle herangehensweise an raumfahrt
erscheint mir teilweise anders zu sein und ich frag mich halt immer gibt es etwas was sie auch gerne in der herangehensweise in europa sehen würden oder sehen sie ein spezifischen europäischen weg den sie eigentlich auch für die bessere wahl halten.
Ja gut also wir haben natürlich in europa immer so etwas skeptisch herangehensweise und so was uns fehlt manchmal so ein bisschen,
wie soll ich sagen dieses begeisterung moment kommt vielleicht auch noch aus dem äh,
erfahrungen des nachkriegs deutschlands kalter krieg da hat man natürlich ist das teil ist große raumfahrt programm speziell auch das apollo programm,
eine ausgeburt des kalten krieges zustands gewesen vielleicht verbinden immer noch viele leute das damit heute sind wir ja wo ganz anders aus.
Wir das thema raumfahrt schon als eine gesellschaft aufgabe denn wir machen viele dinge im weltraum die wir,
ohne die wir machen um einer gesellschaft zu helfen zum beispiel navigationssystem dienste wetter beobachtung satelliten beobachtung satelliten kommunikation sind sie jeder,
laufen heute breit gestreut bevölkerung aber die herangehensweise ist trotzdem hier in europa speziell auch hier in deutschland,
sollen wir mal sehr wirtschaftlich das gedacht man erwartet die wirtschafts erfolge daraus das begeisterung moment ist aber da wenn wir heute.
Astronauten fliegen dann ist das ein großes thema in einer öffentlichkeit die das diskutiert.
Aber man anders als in anderen staaten in frankreich sind in den usa.
Sehen wir immer nur diese spektakuläre raumfahrt und verbinden sie mit viel geld was sie auch kostet aber es ist wenn man es genau nehmen in bruchteil dessen von dem was.
Und die machen wir aber reden wenig drüber es gibt ja viele schon.
Sehr kommerzielle bereiche im bereich raumfahrt sieht war an die kommunikation denken die ist komplett auf raumfahrt angewiesen ja wenn sie.
Fernsehübertragungen machen weltweit dann ist das ein großes großes thema,
für die kommerziellen dienste und ich glaube sie noch nicht so ganz klar viel menschen dass das was,
an begeisterung machen und obendrauf setzen nicht der eigentlich teure teil ist sondern eben der,
das sozusagen das ist nur der kleinere teil also wir geben in deutschland für benannte raumfahrt,
das kann man ja auch mal sagen mal grad hundertdreißig millionen euro aus.
Das ist nun wahrlich nicht viel ja wir geben in ganz europa für das thema bemannten raumfahrt in ungefähr ein euro pro mensch aus.
Auch nicht so viel.
Das sind kleine summen aber die wirklich größere summen die laufenden anderen bereichen und die,
leistung für sowas hängt natürlich stark davon ab wie diese anderen bereiche sind also,
wenn sie wenn sie die begeisterung themen haben wie astronomische raumfahrt oder eben raumfahrt in die tiefen unseres weltraum.
Glauben die leute uns das aber die waren kosten die entstehen ganz woanders und die sind auch notwendig die müssen die waren ausgaben müssen wir tätigen da das sind die aufgaben die wir brauchen um unsere gesellschaft.
Störungsfrei.
Durch die durch die schwierigen randbedingungen zu bewegen sie brauchen heute ein satelliten navigationssystem und das kostet sehr viel geld,
jetzt allein für die nächste verlinkt sind von der eu rund zehn milliarden euro allein dafür vorgesehen.
Dienste die wir einfach täglich nutzen und gar nicht wissen dass sie bezahlt werden.
Also ich würde mir manchmal schon wünschen dass das ähnlich begeistert gesehen wird wie andere technik bereiche ja wieso das auto denke riesen,
messen ob's zeitgemäß ist oder nicht aber das gibt's halt schon,
da gibt es große technik begeisterung in der raumfahrt gibt sie nicht nicht so was kann man verbessern sehen wir ja jetzt auch in den usa also wenn sie einen raketen haben die plötzlich wieder zurückkommen dann stehen millionen auf der straße,
gucken sich das an also es hat schon einen hohen begeisterung gratis deswegen kann aber ist natürlich schwierig für eine raumfahrt.
Das darzustellen denn wir sind in vielen fällen weg von der bildfläche also wenn sie die rakete gestartet haben sehen sie davon nie wieder was ja plus noch wenn sie zufällig fernseh kameras mitnehmen oder sowas aber die meisten satelliten.
Von denen sehen sie vielleicht mal bilder abends auf matteo sat oder sowas,
oder mal das eine oder andere bild auf in irgendeiner zeitung zum thema erdbeer beobachtung dass die meisten dieser informationen in laboren dann weiterverarbeitet werden oder,
in unserer analytics zentren das wissen natürlich viele nicht aber die raum fordern sich ein großer wirtschaftszweig geworden hat aber für viele,
keine unmittelbare spürbare auswirkung auf ihr tägliches leben obwohl so ist.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die regel ich denk die rosita mission hat da auch gezeigt dass dass das mit der.
Ich habe gesagt also das ist der bereich der immer sehr stark öffentlich begleitet wird aber wissen sie auch eine rose der mission ist ja ein relativ kleines thema im gesamtkontext raumfahrt.
Aber sie ist sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr auffällig sehr illustration deshalb die mission die am ende begeistern dass das treibt alle hoch,
aber der fahrer der große teil neunzig prozent unserer ausgaben tätigen wir heute in bereichen das sind service teile ja da machen wir so bis nichts anderes.
Ist ein bisschen unsexy.
Nein will ich nicht sagen also auch.
Für die beteiligten natürlich auf gar keinen fall weil wenn sie sagen
ist ganz interessant also mal hör ich ein ein ein wir als die raumfahrt szene ein wir die bevölkerung heraus und natürlich ist das verhältnis zwischen der öffentlichkeit und den eingeweihten,
ein interessantes freue mich nur wo steht die politik in dem moment,
auf welcher seite weil die erkenntnis darüber wie wichtig die raumfahrt ist denke ich mal herrscht ja vor in der politik.
Sicher aber die die politik steht da wo wir sie haben wollen das sind die politik ist die gesellschaft das sind wir den wir alle die frage ist wie kriegen wir solche themen die notwendig sind auf die agenda der politik.
Dass das raumfahrt thema in deutschland nicht unbedingt ein top priorität steht ist klar aber es könnte helfen ein an top-priorität stehendes thema nämlich zum beispiel den klimawandel stark zu begleiten,
so müssen wir es glaube ich sehen und dass wir sagen wie wie hängen wir das an die,
die großen aufgaben wie wir zu bewältigen haben so in war wie wir heute die navigation dienste,
selbstverständlich voraussetzen als immer da und immer verfügbar niemals gestört und so weiter,
damit für unsere autos durch den verkehr fahren können oder so wie wir heute telekommunikationsstruktur als immer vorhanden sind es wird erwartet dass man,
was immer auch weltweit passiert in der gleichen minute schon,
auf dem bildschirm daheim haben kann und es geht nur nach wie vor nur mit satelliten.
Ein land was mit dieser eigene motivation offensichtlich kein problem zu haben scheint es china
dort gibt es planungen für eine neue raumstation die china station soll in den nächsten jahren entstehen in etwa so groß wie die russische mia also natürlich nicht so ein riesen projekt wie es aber trotzdem es wird.
Geplant es wird
gebaut wird betrieben es wird gemacht andere mission gab es auch auch zum mond also im prinzip gibt's derzeit irgendwie gar nichts in der raumfahrt wo die chinesen nicht in irgendeiner form versuchen
mindestens den anschluss zu finden wenn ich sogar auch eine technologische führerschaft zu übernehmen wie sehen sie,
den weg chinas an dieser stelle und vor allem wie sehen sie gut die kooperation europas mit china aufgestellt.
Der weg ist logisch ja so muss man 's machen wenn man.
Eine führungsrolle übernehmen will weltweit das wollen sie ja auch technologisch und natürlich werden wir uns zu arrangieren haben mit unseren chinesischen partnern an der stelle auch.
Wie alle space fairy nations natürlich ein interesse haben einer engen zusammenarbeit bei den meisten projekte.
Dahinter stehen natürlich auch strategische überlegungen so in china so an anderer stelle auch man darf nie vergessen wo die raumfahrt herkommt die kommt aus dem militärischen bereich und natürlich geht nach wie vor viele aufgaben daran insofern ist auch immer,
eine gewisse distanz zu wahren zu allem was politisch anders ist und anders läuft.
Aber wir versuchen natürlich schon da wo es geht eben zusammenzuarbeiten also das ist schon auch gut zu sehen was sie machen es gibt.
Für uns schon spannende dinge sie machen also jetzt gerade die letzte mond mission die zum ersten mal überhaupt in der menschheitsgeschichte auf die rückseite des monats gegangen ist wo sie für kurze zeit,
in robert betrieben haben so eine spannende sache muss man neidlos anerkennen tolle sache wunderbar,
und da werden wir natürlich auch gerne das ein oder andere mal mitmachen wir diskutieren auch viel mit unseren chinesischen kollegen was wir da machen können auf der anderen seite haben wir auch immer das problem des technologie transfers,
der kritisch zu sehen ist und das patent schutze sind china der auch nicht so ganz einfach für uns zu durchblicken ist.
Was wird denn schon gemacht gemeinsam.
Ja wir nehmen jetzt haben wir grad diskutieren wir gerade über semple return mission von zum erkundung mission zur asteroiden äh die chinesen haben uns dazu eingeladen da haben wir jetzt eine kleine arbeitsgruppe aufgesetzt,
wir wollen auch in den zukünftigen mond mission teilnehmen und natürlich ist es für uns auch interessant,
gerade auch da haben wir gerade ein vertrag auf sind wir gerade am vertrag an aufsetzen experimente auf den chinesischen.
Vor station zu machen also das was sie zurzeit im orbit machen oder später mal auf den,
station da versuchen wir schon die möglichkeiten sie nutzen die sie uns bieten ja und.
Da können wir auch beide voneinander lernen.
Die astronauten trainings laufen ja zum teil schon zusammen ja muss man auch sehen also man denkt durchaus drüber nach wie man die leute irgendwann mal,
in so ein gemeinsames unterfangen bringen kann im erdnahen orbit.
Europäische astronauten auf der chinesischen raumstation ist das eine option.
Na also zumindestens lernen die chinesisch die europäische ja also es gibt schon natürlich überlegungen.
Noch eine sprache.
Es gibt schon überlegungen das zu machen das ist ja auch vernünftig ich meine was es macht ja keinen sinn dass man alles doppelter findet und was wir zusammen machen können sollten wir zusammen machen das immer auch eine gewisse skepsis dabei ist ist normal denke ich das.
Ja aber grad jetzt werde ich mich wieder in das gespräch mit sieg montieren das ist eine der sachen die ja auch angemahnt hat und gewisser hinsicht finde ich ist ja die raumfahrt ohnehin auch mal ganz unabhängig von dem was,
getan wird einfach auch so ein prototyp einer globalen verständigung news wo es mir das so stark aufgefallen wie im gespräch mit astronauten ehemaligen,
astronauten dass sie sich so vorkommen entkoppelt haben von diesem national staatlichen denken hin zu so einem globalen kooperations,
ansatz der einfach gar nicht mehr bereit ist diese erde gebundene diskussion zu führen.
Ja gut das haben wir natürlich jetzt nicht nur in der raumfahrt das haben sie in der sport szene das haben sie in der bergsteiger szene das haben sie in vielen stellen ich denke wenn leute.
Ja gut aber beim sport geht es darum wer die medaillen wieder mit nach hause nimmt das ist ja.
Also ich würde das jetzt nicht unbedingt als eine reine raumfahrt eines raumfahrt phänomen bezeichnen aber das haben sie in vielen technik bereichen auch dass man eben sehr eng zusammenarbeiten wir sind nun mal sehr global mittlerweile aufgestellt wo wollen sie den grenzen ziehen.
Wenn sie nicht so nationalstaat grenzen sind ja auch manchmal sehr künstlich es muss man ja auch mal ehrlicherweise sagen.
Insofern ist es schon normal aber es ist richtig dass man grade in so einem bereich raumfahrt sehr eng zusammenarbeiten muss weil eben auch das geld gar nicht da ist wer zum mond will muss es in einer weltweiten kooperation machen sonst gibt's gar keine chance wird man,
überhaupt keine möglichkeit,
und wie gesagt auch eine internationale raumstation ist eben ein internationales unterfangen und ein,
da fangen bei dem viele zusammenarbeiten müssen und ich kann mir gut aus vorstellen ich war selber nie astronaut,
aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass wenn man da oben so eine schicksalsgemeinschaft bildet dann sieht man das so dieser logisch würde jeder so machen glaube ich wer alles andere wäre verwunderlich,
das ist eine globale geschichte wenn man die erde umkreist versteht man die ehre als globus als eine einheit ja.
Schicksalsgemeinschaft erde.
Schicksalsgemeinschaft erde und so ist es der letztlich auch ich meine egal was wir hier machen.
Alle jetzt über sieben milliarden menschen hängen daran ob es uns gelingt diese herausforderung globaler wandel,
so anzugehen dass wir am ende dieses jahrhunderts alle menschen die auf dieser erde leben zumindest vernünftig ernähren können.
Sie dich hinkriegen haben und vor allem auch unter lebenswerte bedingungen noch haben und ich glaube das ist zum ersten mal jetzt erkannt worden,
in in der generation dass man eine gemeinschaftliche menschheit aufgabe vor sich hat,
die raumfahrt hat zumindest einen kleinen teil dazu beigetragen indem sie nämlich den global blick geöffnet hat wir werden heute,
viele teile unserer erde wahrscheinlich nicht so gut kennen lang nicht so gut kennen wenn's nicht erdbeer obacht von satelliten gäbe wo wir genau sehen was eigentlich passiert zum beispiel in den polar region,
ändert unser leben in der zukunft das bildet sich ab und wir können heute praktisch jeden fleck der erde,
perfekt einsehen und können sehen was dort passiert und wie uns das beeinflussen wird.
Das hatten die menschen vor dreihundert jahre nicht die hatten ihre welt und andere hatten ihre welt die globalen zusammenhänge waren lang nicht klar die sehen wir heute wunderbar und das gibt uns 'ne chance,
die wir hoffentlich auch nutzen.
Jetzt,
ich wollte nochmal kurz auf diese neue ausrichtung auch durch die privatisierung der raumfahrt kurz eingehen europa,
hat ja eigentlich
eines der erfolgreichsten raketen programme der letzten jahrzehnte gefahren mit ariane spass und insbesondere dem standort kurs der prinzip eigentlich so der beste standort ist den man eigentlich für ein raketenstart,
so haben kann und man hat sich eben auch lange zeit damit schmücken können dass man die im prinzip auch so die fehlerfrei leiste serie von raketenstart hingelegt hat.
Jetzt allerdings hat man das gefühl man wird so ein bisschen rechts überholt durchs bass x andere projekte in den usa die halt insbesondere im bereich der wieder verwertbar kalt von raketen stufen für aufmerksamkeit gemacht haben die debatte darüber,
wie viel das jetzt am ende bringt denk ich mal ist sicherlich noch offen aber wir hatten ja schon angesprochen zumindest setzt es auch wieder so eine neue begeisterung frei und den kann man sich ja auch wie gar nicht entziehen wenn man irgendwie so zwei raketen parallel landen sieht da,
klappt einfach der kiefer nach unten wie reagiert denn jetzt,
europa also mit der wiederverwendbar zeit von raketen dauert noch ein bisschen was sind ja ein forschungsprojekt auch konkret eingebunden desto
versucht experimentell zunächst einmal noch nicht im rahmen einer normalen raketen bauplanung diese technologien zu,
zu testen ende nächsten jahres soll es da glaube ich losgehen ist in der einundzwanzig okay,
ja als hätten sie doch mal kurz was hat es mit karalis toto aufsicht und wie wie sehen sie diese entwicklung in diesem raketen bereich wie wichtig ist das.
Also wir machen das jetzt mit unseren französischen und japanischen partnern zusammen ist ein schönes projekt weil sie einen trilateralen läuft das ist gibt's auch gelungen wir halten es auch so von der geopolitischen ausrüstung glaube ich für ganz vernünftig,
sehr irgendwie japan zusammenarbeiten denn da haben die ähnliche probleme kleine merkt.
Und trotzdem einigermaßen große raumfahrt programm.
Insofern haben wir uns zusammengetan und haben gesagt lass uns mal dinge tun im raum transport die neu sind.
Nicht so neu dass wir jetzt sagen wir müssen alles neu erfinden aber immerhin haben wir natürlich jetzt das thema der rio sibille also der wiederverwendbar von raketen stufen insbesondere der ersten stufe auch angegangen.
Wir sind der meinung dass das was macht noch deutlich verbessert werden kann in der zukunft und das ist auch forschungs- gegenstand also wie können wir.
In zukunft raumfahrt elemente der ersten vielleicht später mal auch sogar der oberstufe wiederverwenden.
Um damit deutlich günstigere kosten erzielen zu können als wir sie heute haben dass das funktioniert zu funktionieren scheint sehen wir heute in den usa.
Da kann man sich jetzt lange drüber streiten was subventionen und was nicht subventioniert aber auch unsere raketen in europa sind stark subventioniert und,
die preise die sie haben sind immer sehr politische preise also da kann man wenig drauf geben aber woran man es vielleicht merken kann dass es funktioniert ist dass man eben mit,
hoher staat sequenz und kadenz in usa arbeiten kann das machen die einfach über ihre.
Die sie haben und da sind sie natürlich mit dieser wiederverwendbar zeit.
Momentan klarem vorteil das muss man so sehen wie es jedenfalls und das heißt,
nachziehen von der forschung seite her deswegen haben wir das begonnen,
das projekt ziel zunächst mal drauf ab überhaupt sein ricky thema anzugehen wie es im spacex gemacht hat es sind senkrecht starten die raketen die,
die unterstützen werden auch senkrecht wieder landen dann ist es relativ klein begonnen mit den bescheidenden mitteln die wir haben,
das projekt muss man sehen ist ja von national level derzeit in frankreich das größte projekt des im im im bereiche raumfahrt forschung gefahren wird.
Als ariane sechs.
Ja gerade eine sechs wird ja hauptsächlich durch die europäische gemeinschaft finanziell also durch die esa durch die durch die partner das ist etwas anderes als die europäische gemeinschaft die esa partner finanzieren das aber im nationalen rahmen,
hat frankreich ist gemacht und die franzosen war's die uns auch vorgeschlagen haben diesen gemeinsamen weg zu gehen die halten den für sinnvoll,
und wir halten den vor allem sinnvoll für sinnvoll zu gehen zusammen mit unseren japanischen partnern die gerade wie gesagt ganz ähnliche geopolitischen ideen auch entwickelt haben.
Oder wenn wir ist zunächst mal drauf ablegen dass wir überhaupt stufen wieder senkrecht landen,
vor starten können im gegensatz zu den franzosen die sehr stark auf dieses senkrecht,
landen setzen setzen wir aber auch auf horizontale techniken wird,
wir sind darauf aus äh sehr stark geflügelte unterstützen zu entwickeln die eigenständig sogar wieder zurückkehren können deswegen haben wir zum beispiel noch ein zweites großes projekt das nennen wir reflex return,
experimentell stadium da wird also praktisch versucht,
unter stufen eigenständig zurück fliegen zu können techniken zu entwickeln wie wir die dinger eben auch ohne großen treibstoff aufwand der immer tot maßen darstellt wenn man sie,
wieder zurück fliegen können am ende denke ich es wird eine kombination aus beidem sein nämlich die senkrecht starten und landen dinge aber auch dinge die eigenständig wieder zurück fliegen können,
zu
wir testen dabei sehr viel und deswegen haben wir jetzt eben große teile unseres,
transport programms auf diese e v lounge technologien verlegt.
Und denken dass man da schon.
Erfolg haben wird in der zukunft kalia ist jetzt eben das vor das große vorzeigeprojekt auch im europäischen rahmen.
Das war jetzt nicht auf der agenda aber es ist zumindestens in in den beiden großen ländern frankreich und deutschland jeweils in den nationalen,
forschungsprojekt komm fest verankert hat.
Welche in welchen teil übernimmt da dass das deal er
konkret also ich mein ariane ist passt es ja wesentlichen französisches projekt also es gibt natürlich,
schon immer hier die aktivitäten ich glaube im standort labor hausen werden die triebwerke getestet mitentwickelt bei diesem desto und reflex projekt.
Das projekt stützt sich auf ein japanischer triebwerk dass dort entwickelt worden ist und auch ein triebwerk dass was sie brauchen stark drosselten ist das heißt für den rückflug müssen sie es enorm draußen können und das,
stürzen wir uns auf eine japanische technik,
in der frage der flug stadtteilen gesagt wir schützen wir uns auf die erfahrung die frankreich hat im wie man das ganze jahr von starten aller voraussicht nach,
wir teilen uns viele aufgaben wir machen,
die großen tanks die wasserstoff tanks.
Auf die lande beine ausklappt landebahn eine rakete wir berechnen die die.
Die wärme abgas strahlen die müssen jetzt vorstellen wenn in der rakete landet ist es anders als beim starten der strahl geht nicht nach unten weg sondern schlägt,
der praktisch landen rakete entgegen der mitreden enorme hitze lasten auf wird war bei,
bei den landen stufen wir machen zum beispiel aber auch getrennte entwicklungen der lage regelung systeme und der.
Rückführung systeme also der steuerung der systeme um im unabhängig beurteilen zu können die werden wir nebeneinander her betreiben das in unterschiedlichen flügen natürlich,
aber testen gegen unsere französischen kollegen.
Haben wir partner und und wir haben auch gesagt,
unabhängige control systemen vergleichen die dann hinsichtlich der performance also es ist wie gesagt ein,
ein experimentelle es projekt bei dem wir neue techniken ausprobieren wollen und wir wollen natürlich auch die dynamischen eigenschaften,
dieser fahrzeuge testen denn das ist wichtig wenn sie zurückkehren müssen sie über iron kenntnisse verfügen sie landen ja.
Durch die luft kommt wieder auf der erde und so haben wir uns das jetzt in einem,
umfangreichen katalog in einer entsprechenden arbeitsteilung aufgeteilt sehr kompliziertes aufteilung aber die funktioniert ganz gut die teams arbeiten sehr intensiv jetzt dran und ich hoffe dass wir jetzt ende des jahres,
dann äh die phasen cd also die eigentlichen fertigungsverfahren in zürich freigeben können ja.
Manchmal davon ausgeht dass das alles ganz toll,
funktioniert hat man vielleicht so zweiundzwanzig dreiundzwanzig irgendwie so die technik beisammen bis das dann auch in eine.
Ganz laut länger das erste.
Ich war zu optimistisch schon na ja ich meine dann dauert's noch länger bis es dann irgendwann mal in irgendeine künftige ariane sieben oder acht eingebaut werden kann also wie realistisch ist das dass es irgendwann auch mal konkret zum einsatz kommen kann.
Also wenn sie mich jetzt persönlich fragen geht es ja gar nicht anders.
Also die nächste ariane muss elemente dieser art haben das,
gar nicht anders weil wir sehen ja,
es ist die technik die eben die preise tatsächlich auch sinkt jedenfalls nachdem was ich glaube da können sie immer anders auch rechnen,
aber das was wir sehen es wird nicht anders gehen also man muss sich sowieso mit der frage auseinander setzen.
Wie man eine raketen wie man raketen stufen rückkehr fähig und wiederverwendbar baut.
Das sind viele fragen die damit parallel zu beantworten sind ja sie wissen wahrscheinlich dass wir.
Zwar in europa und da wirklich vorderster front wasserstoff technologie entwickelt haben das heißt die großen triebwerke die wir heute betreiben dürfen alle auf wasserstoff basis wasserstoff sauerstoff verbrennung.
Effektivste form chemischen antrieb s aber sie hatte am nachteile wenn sie sie wiederverwenden wollen haben sie,
die versprüht jung war durch den wasserstoff das heißt triebwerke können nur eine begrenzte zeit wieder verwendet werden.
Und wenn man dann in höhere bereiche kommt space extrem jetzt bis zu zehnfache wieder verwendung an dann wird's für der wasserstoff verbrennung sind kritisch dann gehen sie jetzt in den entwicklungen ihrer triebwerke ja kein wasserstoff verwenden,
jetzt auf die metallen verbrennung und das ist zum beispiel ein großes thema was wir angehen.
Also es sind viele dinge die man parallel angehen will und die wahrscheinlich den raum transport in den nächsten jahren stark.
Ändern werden dahingehend dass es 'ne ganze variabilität in dem übergangsbereich gibt von raum fahrzeugen wo man das alles,
wird und auch schauen wird wie man die kosten tatsächlich sinken kann denn ohne kosten senkung wird es immer schwieriger.
Eine kompetitive raumfahrt betreiben zu können das ist glaube ich allen klar.
Und da wird am ende eben das cleverste konzept gewinnen.
Aber letzten endes muss das ja auch mit ein bisschen mehr ausnutzung aus dieser ganzen technologie angehen in meiner ist richtig mitbekomme als ein
oft geäußert der kritikpunkt dass so ein standort wie coros schlicht und ergreifend zu wenig staatsrat um einfach diese ganzen
kosten auch langfristig gut stimmen zu können also.
Das liegt aber daran dass wir jetzt eben raketen verwenden die sehr teuer sind natürlich.
Das bedingt einander ein wenig ne.
Ja aber sie brauchen natürlich das darf man auch nicht vergessen sie braucht wenn sie eine nation sind eine gesellschaft wie dieses große europa mit über dreihundert millionen menschen.
Die brauchen ja ihren eigenen raum transport.
Darf mal erinnern wie der europäische raum transport überhaupt zustande gekommen ist in den,
jahren und als man sich dann zusammensetzten und aus der eltern.
European parlament organisation sowas wie die isar gemacht hat und es ist ariane programm überhaupt aufgelegt hat,
es ist im umstand geschuldet gewesen hauptsächlich dem umstand auch dass deutschland da eingetreten ist das damals zu den olympischen spielen in münchen ein telekommunikation satelliten von den amerikanern nicht gestartet wurde.
Da hat man uns das sozusagen das geld verdienen verboten,
und das hat natürlich dazu geführt dass man gesagt hat das kann man als ein gesellschaft system des so technisch orientiert ist wie europa,
nicht anders machen wir brauchen solche raketen wir brauchen sie strategischen gründen und wir müssen die möglichkeit haben,
nicht wie ein auto sie das heute jetzt kein.
Kein strategischer bereich darstellt aber die der raum transport ist strategisch also europa wird sowas immer brauchen auch im großen umfang sonst,
hat man eben probleme also man will natürlich seine eigenen satelliten notfalls im orbit kriegen können ohne,
zu sein von anderen die einen sagen können ja man muss halt zwei jahre später oder drei jahre später wir brauchen ein,
satelliten navigationssystem unabhängig von dem,
von denen die woanders existierenden das sind auch strategische werte die wir haben und wir müssen die erde beobachten.
Auch unabhängig von anderen wie können die daten zwar austauschen,
aber wir sollten uns das nicht nehmen lassen dass wir es auch selber können und insofern eine strategische bedeutung hat es alle mal und deswegen braucht man eben auch wenn man was im weltraum machen will seinen eigenen raum transport des kostet uns halt dann geld.
Es kostet uns in europa derzeit rund eine milliarde im jahr das ist jetzt klingt viel geld ist klar.
Aus hält etwa acht neuntausend menschen im brot und arbeit über ganz europa ich glaube das ist steht einem europa.
Gut investiertes geld ja.
Schon an also deswegen sollten wir jetzt nicht meinen dass wir die kosten frage zu diskutieren ist immer ein bisschen,
schwierig in solchen dingen aber was man machen kann man kann über die effektivität diskutieren kann sagen wie können wir da mehr draus machen aus dem viel geld das wir haben und ich denke,
dann sollte man sich auch die beste technologie gönnen.
Und sollte aber dabei auch gleichzeitig schauen dass die lounge kosten im rahmen bleiben und möglichkeiten geben.
Auch mehr satelliten starten zu können das ist in der tat ein problem dass sowohl die satelliten kosten als auch die lounge kosten stark gestiegen sind.
Jetzt hatten sie sich das mal frei interpretiere etwas skeptisch zu mond mission geäußert im vergleich zu den leo mission nichtsdestotrotz
spielt der mond in der raumfahrt derzeit eine große rolle und auch die
prinzip ja alle die derzeit an der is mitarbeiten haben sich auch zusammengefunden zu einem neuen projektes luna luna,
plattform geht will also quasi einer,
mond station die nicht dauerhaft benannt ist oder befragt out sondern die halt,
einfach da ist um immer mal wieder kurzfristig im betrieb genommen zu werden oder beziehungsweise die ganze zeit im betrieb ist aber nicht unbedingt immer durch astronauten im betrieb gehalten wird,
da geht's ja auch bald los in zwei jahren soll der aufbau in schritten beginnen ich bedeutung hat das,
und was was wird.
Entstehen was ist das für eine langfristige vision die sich aus diesem projekt ableiten.
Na gut die langfristige vision ist kurz beschrieben man will eine station in einen mond auch mitbringen das ist der sogenannte luna.
Bei dem man eine station hat die nicht die erde sondern in dem fall hier tatsächlich einen mond langfristig umkreist von der man dann aus gelegentlich auch auf dem mond oberfläche absteigen kann wie oft es wird sich dann zeigen.
Ja gut aber ist ja kein selbstzweck also was was.
Naja das er hat ja gut das ist das ist zunächst mal ein großes forschungsprojekt gramm würde ich mal sagen meine.
Ja okay.
Jetzt kann man sich natürlich darüber streiten ob das,
nicht auch anders machbar ist da bin ich durchaus der meinung bräuchte man nicht unbedingt nur geld wäre aber es gibt halt viele die sagen ja dann können wir schnell auf jeden punkt der erde wir haben auch eine gewisse sicherheit für astronauten die sie auf dem mond aufhalten wenn sie dann,
in not kommen dann sind sie zumindestens in einer mond umlaufbahn sicherer aber wir müssen auch die zeit spannend sehen in denen sich sowas aufbau.
Das ist mal ganz kurz der rahmen indem wir uns da bewegen es ist in vorrangig natürlich ein forschung.
Es geht darum den mond als sehen uns nächsten himmelskörper besser untersuchen zu können.
Als physiker muss ich sagen tolle sache ja das ist natürlich das was ich mir wünsche der mond ist.
Obwohl wir neunzehnhundertneunundsechzig zum ersten mal die amerikaner dort gelandet sind eigentlich immer noch ein,
objekt dass wir nicht so gut kennen wie wir es glauben kennen zu können oder vielleicht glauben dass wir es kennen den masken wird deutlich besser mittlerweile als den mond,
der mond ist schon interessantes objekt in der untersuchung.
Jetzt ist natürlich die frage wie groß ist der aufwand der dafür ist es gerechtfertigt ist das alles möglich,
in welchem zeitschiene denken und arbeiten wir da und da ist habe ich also meine befürchtungen,
weil wir halt relativ wenig geld dafür haben also für dieses gewaltige unterfangen haben wir gerade in europa eigentlich kaum geld ja wir diskutieren ein sehr kleines programm,
zum thema expo ration zugehört dieses monat thema ja auch unter anderem auch die ecken die raumstation.
Das sind mal grad sechshundert millionen im jahr dass die raumstation heraus zu finanzieren da ist das zu finanzieren was wir auf dem mond machen wollen in zukunft und dieses programm.
Umfasst ja nicht nur den mond sondern es geht auch darum wie man dann da vielleicht eines tages auch mal in richtung maß aufbrechen kann das entscheidende bei all diesen programmen ist und das muss ich immer sagen ist.
Wie wie kritisch finanziert man das wenn man 's unter kritisch finanziert,
ein ding story ich vergleich es mal wenn sie jetzt vom großen haus träumen.
Und ihr einkommen ist klein und sie beschließen sich jede woche ein stein zu kaufen für ihr neues haus da wird es in diesem leben nichts.
Und es ist sinnlos das programm für sie persönliche seite sie haben da irgendwelche,
anderen ideen dabei das heißt sie brauchen wenn sie ein bestimmtes projekt machen immer auch eine kritische finanzierung das ist in überschaubaren zeiträume hinbekommen.
Und die frage ist einfach wie groß müssen die überschaubaren zeiträume sein sind es hundert jahre sind es fünfzig jahre sind zwanzig jahre oder nur zehn jahre.
Ein bisschen unfair in der debatte derzeit finde ich das über diese zeit schienen sehr unklar geredet wird.
Nach außen hin wird der eindruck erweckt als ob das alles innerhalb der zehn jahren möglich ist jetzt will ich ihnen mal ein beispiel geben wenn wir heute den mond denken.
Und vergleichen was in den jahren neunzehnhunderteinundsechzig bis neunzehn neunundsechzig an aufwendungen in den usa aufgebracht worden sind um auf dem mond tatsächlich in einer einzigen dekade zu kommen.
Dann war das etwa fünf prozent des gesamten us haushalts dafür verwendet worden ist heute verwenden die usa war gerade null komma fünf prozent also zehn mal weniger geld dafür in europa ist es noch gesund.
Wenn wir mit den geldbeträge die wir heute haben in der raumfahrt damals unter den bedingungen neunzehnhunderteinundsechzig des idee gehabt hätten zum mond zu kommen da werden wir jetzt noch nicht dort.
Fünfzig jahre.
Und das heißt man muss auch die budget sehen die man hat und die realistische des realistische handeln dahinter organisieren man kann nicht sagen.
Man hat man wird schon mal irgendwann fertig werden.
Das geht nicht das man muss auch wissen in welchen zeit schieben man denken kann und die gelder die wir momentan haben nämlich jene.
Sechshundert millionen wo die raumstation schon mit dabei ist also dreihundert millionen würde ich mal sagen die hälfte davon,
die wir wirklich ein geld haben um auf dem mond zu kommen pro jahr reicht natürlich bei weitem mich für europa um eine bedeutende rolle wird im programm spielen zu können da muss viel mehr geld müsste viel mehr geld kommen.
Das muss man wissen das wissen natürlich auch diejenigen die das entscheiden aber in der öffentlichkeit wird oft so der eindruck erweckt als ob das jetzt schon in den nächsten jahren mal irgendwie passiert es ist schon ein bisschen enttäuschend wenn man das so sieht.
Und da bitte ich immer auch um vorsicht also das ist wir müssen sehen wie viel geld wir da rein.
Dann können wir ihn ungefähr sagen wie lange das dauert wird wenn wir sagen.
Das ist eine aufgabe die sich für die nächsten übernächste und vielleicht die der nachfolgende generationen unserer urenkel auch noch lohnt dann würde ich sagen okay dann fangen wir es halt an aber da müssen wir uns darüber im klaren sein dass wir.
Dessen wo anfangen.
Lass mir doch das geld mal kurz aus den diskussionen raus und zeigt mir einfach mal was was möglich sein könnte auch mit einer solchen plattform selbst wenn man sie jetzt.
Technische lösung kritisch sieht wenn das ding da ist was würde sich denn damit realisieren lassen.
Also was jetzt auch wirklich begeisterung.
Ja gut also erstmal könnten wir damit durch den mond in exzellenter weise untersuchen wir werden viel mehr verstehen der mond ist ja.
In vielerlei hinsicht noch ein rätsel für uns hat.
Besonderheiten die wir noch nicht verstanden haben auch die herkunft des mondes ist nicht klar wir wissen nicht es ist mal.
Es ist sozusagen ein stück das rausgeschlagen worden ist aus der erde eines in den frühen entstehungsprozess phasen oder hat das ist eingefangen das objekt da gibt es viele theorien drüber aber die zusammenhänge zwischen erde und mond,
sind schon wesentlich in der bedeutung verständnis unseres ärzte systems und der mond ist natürlich auch ein wunderbares archiv einer alten erde also das was wir auf dem mond sehen so könnten wir uns vielleicht vorstellen wie unsere erde mal ausgesehen hat.
Was die gestein zusammensetzung angeht,
der mond hat aber auch sonst viele besonderheiten und ist natürlich ein objekt dass wir auch zu beobachtung benutzen könnten also zu beobachtung um top beobachtungen aufstellen zu stationen aufstellen zu können.
Ich sag jetzt mal einfach spielen ich mal so ein bisschen in die zukunft stellen sie ein astronomische observatorium auf dem mond auf können sie ohne störenden einfluss der erdatmosphäre.
Und sie haben viel viel mehr möglichkeiten in dem zusammenspiel zwischen erden mond zum beispiel im aufbau großer teleskope wurde das was wir wollen,
bislang in der firma rechnen also wo sie zum beispiel,
beobachtungsstelle station auf mond und erde zusammen schalten um gigantische,
zu entwickeln damit wir unsere sterne beobachten zu können der mond bietet uns wissenschaft.
Ungeheure viele möglichkeiten das muss man sagen und wir müssen ihn in der gesamtheit verstehen das heißt jetzt nicht nur spots wo man mal landet und ein bisschen die steine sammeln sondern muss es als globalen großen körper sehen.
Und da glaube ich also oder bin mir ziemlich sicher dass wir da vieles noch überhaupt noch nicht mal gesehen haben oder geschweige denn dann verstanden haben.
Insofern ist der mond für uns als als erden bürger,
das nächstgelegene und wahrscheinlich interessanteste objekt obwohl auf den ersten blick vielleicht ein bisschen langweilig erscheint da gibt's andere da gibt's interessantere monte im sonnensystem auf den ersten blick ja.
Die sind aber weiter weg.
Die sind weiter weg noch länger und da fliegt man auch deutlich länger hin das schafft man nicht in drei tagen das schafft man dann in drei jahren oder in zehn jahren.
Ja ähnlich sieht das ja auch eine neue garde von kleineren unternehmen fliegen so verschiedene begriffe im raum news findet schon angesprochen,
ich hatte ja auch vor einiger zeit das projekt partei glaube ich nicht mittlerweile im planetarium transportsysteme umbenannt haben ist
die abkürzung steht noch spreche gibt's engagierte junge unternehmen die vollständig außerhalb des bisherigen kontext versuchen eigene lösungen anzustreben und dabei unter anderem den mond im,
auge haben wie sehr kooperiert das so mit den etablierten staatlich getriebenen forschungs- instituten wir sind da so die diplomatischen beziehungen.
Ja gut wir kennen das alles und das ist ja auch nett und es ist keine konkurrenz wenn sie das glauben gegenteil ich finde sowas net,
sich immer damit beschäftigt man muss sich nur darüber im klaren sein was heißt jetzt kommerziell aufm mond.
Ist das ziel.
Kommerziellen aktivitäten zu entfalten was ich mir schwer vorstellen kann oder sind es unternehmen die darauf zielen aufgaben zu übernehmen.
Die staatlich organisiert schwierig zu machen sind also dann etwa.
Transport aufgaben und so sind ja die meisten auch angelegt von unserem wissenschaftlichen geräten zum mond insofern ist interessant was gemacht wird wo wir können unterstützen wir das auch.
Es ist nicht immer ganz einfach weil die erwartungen immer die ist dass das auch eine kontinuität er fährt aber ich habe ihn ja grade geschildert wie.
Wie klein die budgets letztlich sind die wir haben und das ist natürlich schon die frage ob wir ein so großes wissenschaftliches programm entwickeln können das also transportunternehmen auf dauer nähert.
Wenn sie es so machen wie es bei sechs hat ja damit begonnen dass sie gesagt haben wir fliegen eines tages viele viele menschen zum,
zum mond und dann haben sie gesagt das machen wir nicht nur einen ganz kleinen stil sondern wir fliegen gleich,
zehntausend zum mond eines tages und dann denken sie ins nächste jahrhundert in den nächsten jahrhunderte hinein,
dann haben sie eine vision gegen die sie an arbeiten können ob es geld müssen natürlich erstmal auf der erde verdienen.
Insofern muss man sehr genau beobachten was diese unternehmen jetzt vorhaben was ich ausschließen kann ist glaube ich dass man.
Kommerzielle aktivitäten auf dem mond entfalten kann man kann forschungs- aufgaben,
unterstütz.
Die ein oder andere entwicklungs- aufgabe günstiger anbietet das glaube ich schon.
Und da wird man sich auch mit denen zusammenarbeiten und im grunde ist es ja auch zu begrüßen denn ich meine nur nur die konkurrenz bringt die preise am ende runter das muss man ja auch mal sehen und äh,
insofern ich steh dem sehr positiv und offen gegenüber.
Ist nicht immer ganz einfach für uns jetzt in das ein oder andere thema hinein zu springen wir müssen ja auch offen agieren es gibt viele am markt die was machen wollen,
wir als große staatliche organisationen hinderlich auch neutral und.
Wir können uns jetzt nicht in der einen oder anderen richtung orientieren also heißt warum habt ihr denn da nicht mitgemacht da muss ich mal sagen das muss man wettbewerb ausschreiben in ganz europa.
Aber letztendlich denke ich wäre es doch zu begrüßen ich meine wenn man sagt ziele ein teil der raumfahrt abgesehen jetzt von dem was wir schon besprochen hatten so betrieb wichtiger infrastrukturen für
die eu oder die gesellschaft an sich natürlich ist halt vor allem die unterstützung der der forschung und der wissenschaft wäre es ja sinnvoll
wenn so dinge wie der transport zum mond um da erst mal hinzukommen um da wissenschaft zum
von anderen unternehmen einfach übernommen werden würde und man sozusagen diesen teil ich auch noch an der backe hat.
Stimmt das ist richtig also da bin ich ja voll dafür die frage ist es nur wo kommt das geld her.
Um überhaupt erstmal in dieses stadium zu kommen dass es leute gibt die damit geld verdienen können.
Das wird eben meistens auch staatlich vor finanziert und die frage ist jetzt ist es gerechtfertigt oder nicht.
Diese diskussion die haben wir noch nicht so zur gänse geführt.
Ich würde es begrüßen wenn in der tat mehr privates geld auch in diese entwicklung.
Ist in usa deutlich mehr als in europa also ich sage mal deutlich da reden wir über größenordnung.
Und wenn in dem moment wo sich unternehmen aufschwüngen würden und sagen ja wir machen das.
Dann aber auch den ein oder anderen staats- aufgabe kriegen ist es ja in ordnung wenn aber alles hundert prozent,
aus staats aufträgen finanziert wird und daraus dann irgendwann uns vor,
wird in ferner zukunft mein geschäft machen zu können dann wird 's wirklich schwierig einordnen war,
weil wir wissen ja nie was dann passiert also dann dann kann man es auch erstmal alleine machen also alleine in dem sinn dass es eben so organisiert wird wie in der vergangenheit auch gemacht worden ist,
also die private risikobereitschaft siehst schon entscheidend.
Aber das ist eben auch etwas was in usa anders organisiert ist wenn sie heute diesen großen launchen unternehmen gehen die haben natürlich,
vor menschen in den weltraum tatsächlich zu bringen das ist der business case.
Wir haben in europa derzeit keine entwicklung.
Die den transport von menschen auf raketen möglich macht noch nicht mal staatlich gesehen die großen privatunternehmen aber.
Der bremsen mit seiner firma ist oder ob das mit seinem spacex ist haben immer im mittelpunkt stehen die frage wie kriegen wir menschen im weltraum.
Das scheint wenn man mit den leuten redet auch die große geschäftsidee zu sein.
Wobei er ist europa nicht ganz unbeteiligt ist also die kapsel die hat jetzt demnächst die astronauten zuerst bringen soll.
Ja gut aber das ist jetzt.
Der europäische entwicklung.
Das stimmt aber die das ist jetzt ein rein staatlich finanziertes projekt das hat ja das steht im rahmen der der großen pläne im luna das hat jetzt nichts mit diesem privat pläne zu tun.
Die sind tatsächlich angelegt auf einen kommerziellen transport von menschen in den weltraum.
Wenn man mit den leuten redet ist das eines der ganz großen ziele in europa kenne ich das nicht also der plant es keiner das ist noch nicht mal wie gesagt unser programm sieht es vor.
Ja vor allem hört man oft auch das stichwort tourismus glaube dass etwas was hier eher skeptisch gesehen wird oder.
Ja warum nein ich sehe es nicht so optisch ich meine klar wenn sie jetzt in grade in umwelt debatten stehen wohl natürlich jeder flug schon kritisch.
Ist natürlich schwierig über solche themen zu reden aber es fangen wir mal anders an,
der luftverkehr den wir heute kennen der hat sich entwickelt über tourismus,
das ist eine der wesentlichen triebfeder dieses dieses flugverkehr gewesen,
und wenn sie die ersten flug passagiere wenn man die überhaupt so nennen darf oder pioniere die,
geflogen sind auf den ersten transatlantische pflügen eines charles lindberg hinten drin sitzen,
über.
Das ist eigentlich eher investoren ne.
Dann waren das leute die investoren abenteurer waren die hätten sie doch in zwanziger jahren nie vorstellen können dass heute zig tausende von menschen jeden tag,
in zigtausende von flugzeug ich habe neulich mal gelernt zehntausend flugzeuge sind praktisch immer in der luft.
Über die weltmeere fliegen und kontinente besuchen und ein großer teil davon ist tourismus,
müssen wir sehen dann kann man natürlich schon die frage stellen warum soll es nicht auch tourismus in den weltraum geben warum soll es nicht irgendwann eines tages tourismus auf den mond geben und warum,
wusste so teuer sein denn was in den zwanziger jahren wahrscheinlich vermögen gekostet hat nämlich im flugzeug zu kissen sitzen das können sie heute für ein paar hundert euro kriegen ja sondern nach new york oder wer weiß wohin fliegen,
für ein paar hundert euro,
oder nach japan habe ich jetzt fünfhundert euro das ist bayern in zwanziger jahren gemessen an den einkommen völlig unvorstellbar ja und es ist geholt genauso,
also ich glaube schon dass man sowas entwickeln kann und darauf zielt es natürlich und warum und jetzt frage ich mich,
sollte sich dem eine gesellschaft grundsätzlich widersetzen.
Auch der luftverkehr den wir heute haben ist durch viel staatlichen subventionen geschaffen worden wir haben in diesen tagen gerade fünfzig jahre airbus gefeiert ja die firma.
Dazu eingeladen und da ist natürlich als die groß flugzeuge entwickelt worden sind wie damals airbus dreihundert dass er nicht alles mit privatem geld finanziert worden der großteil davon ist auch mit öffentlichen investitionen unterstützt worden,
und so hat man eben auch flugverkehr aufgebaut und der heute ein gigantischer markt darstellt also ich würde jetzt nicht von vornherein ausschließen dass das kein thema für die öffentliche hand ist ja das finde ich nicht gut.
Da müssen wir auch gucken wie sie sowas entwickelt und ich glaube schon,
dass der menschen der transport von menschen auch für tourismus durchaus ein thema sein könnte was wir in den öffentlichen diskussionen auch mal.
Haben sollten und nicht nur einfach abreißen sollten und sagen na das interessiert uns nicht.
Ja wir haben ja auch gelernt die science-fiction blickt nicht nur in die zukunft sondern ist auch in der lage sie voraus zu sagen schon mit stanley kubik hat ja schon ein hilton hotel bei uns in den orbit gepackt,
fehlt dann halt noch mal gucken vielleicht kommen wir da auch hin ja haben sie zum,
schluss des gesprächs noch eine botschaft die wir noch mitnehmen sollten dich vielleicht noch nicht angeregt habe hier zu besprechen.
Was wünschen sie sich denn so was demnächst mal passieren sollte.
Ja erstmal immer klar gut es ist jetzt ein leichter wunsch den kann ich sagen wir brauchen deutlich mehr geld.
Das war jetzt so einfach.
Das war so einfach das dachte ich mir schon das wollen sie nicht hören,
aber das ist tatsächlich das problem das wir haben wir brauchen.
Aber auch eine zusammenarbeit deine weltweite zusammenarbeit die jetzt ein bisschen schwieriger geworden ist in letzter zeit das muss man außer da würde ich mir doch wünschen dass wir,
das eines tages wieder so haben dass wir an einem strang ziehen wenn's um raumfahrt geht und nicht die systeme gegeneinander arbeiten müssen,
was wir momentan grad so ein bisschen in der entwicklung sehen es wird das würde die sache doch deutlich nach vorne bringen und,
gut was ich glaube was die botschaft ist das raumfahrt in dieser gesellschaft in unserer gesellschaft sowieso aber auch weltweit,
in den nächsten.
In diesem jahr runter was in den nächsten fünfzig bis hundert jahren eine große große rolle spielen wird immer mehr und immer bedeutende rolle wir werden viele aufgaben nur unter zu hilfe name von satelliten auf dieser erde,
erledigen können,
und was mir dann wünsche letzte wunsch dass wir dann auch die beiträge leisten können und dieses gigantische thema global change angehen zu können da wird man raumfahrt massiv brauchen.
Ja herr titus vielen dank für die ausführung ihre gedanken dazu wie es so aufgestellt ist derzeit mit der raumfahrt ich werd sie hier auf jeden fall bei raum zeit noch weiter verfolgen,
vielen vielen dank.
Vielen dank.
Ja und vielen dank wie immer für's zuhören hier bei raum zeit jeden monat geht's weiter und bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis bald.